[Music]
the use of glass as an artistic medium
dates back to ancient egypt
despite the obvious fragility of glass
sculptures this art form has an enduring
appeal the transparency of glass often
has a ghostly quality they're tangible
works of art that are skillfully crafted
[Music]
with this glass sculpture of a horse
the artist's two passions come together
art and horsemanship
[Music]
the artist takes inspiration from her
horse observing the swell of his muscles
as he romps in order to create the same
sense of movement in glass
she then draws a series of sketches of
the horse in different stances
these sketches are an artistic study
they help her work out the sculpture's
form before actually creating one
she cleaned solid glass rods to prepare
them for sculpting
this is borosilicate glass which is more
resistant to thermal shock than other
kinds of glass
she brings the glass into the flame of a
torch to soften it
once softened she can fuse two of the
rods together then using tweezers and
flat knife-like tools she sculpts the
glass into the shape of the horse's hips
and legs
she works quickly so the glass doesn't
have a chance to cool and fracture
[Music]
she adds a smaller piece of glass and
forms it into a tail
she constantly turns the glass as she
works it to make sure it looks good from
all angles
she melts glass in front of the hips to
build up the body and shape the horse's
belly back and chest
this is intensive and precision work
the piece must be exposed to a
well-adjusted flame and constantly moved
so it doesn't become too hot and melt
too much
she adds glass to the front and sculpts
the shoulders and part of the front legs
she removes a little piece of extra
glass
she deposits this sizzling unwanted bit
in water to cool it down
and dispose of it safely
she does more work on the front legs
she'll refine them and form hooves later
but now she bakes the partially sculpted
glass horse in a kiln this is the first
annealing which realigns molecules to
prevent cracking
she forms the head and main separately
from the body this is more intricate
work the features are much more detailed
so she uses smaller tools
once she shaped the eye sockets she
melts little blobs of black glass into
them
she sculpts the eyes with a flat knife
she carves creases above them to create
an eyelid effect
she adds glass for the ears
then using a tool called a masher she
pinches the ears to squeeze them thinner
she heats them again
this process can cause the ears to stick
together so she cuts them to separate
them
she curls the ears using tweezers and
tweaks their position on the horse's
head
[Music]
she melts the base of the head to the
body and they become one
she fuses more glass to the back to
craft a mane and after another annealing
she returns to the legs
[Music]
she softens them with a flame again and
adds definition to the fetlock joints
she cuts the tips to create a more level
surface
she melts black glass onto the ends of
the legs and sculpts it into the shape
of hooves
[Music]
with a series of tools she tweaks each
hoof until she's satisfied this glass
horse will stand the way she wants it to
after another annealing she shines a
polarized light through the sculpture
and examines it for stresses that could
compromise its structure
finding none this galloping work of
glass art is complete it's been made
with great care and caring
[Music]
you